edbert auzalei will pitch for chicago he
is making his second start of the year
the first one came against the cardinals
and the cardinals couldn't figure him
out colton wong being told to take a
couple of seconds by our home plate on
pyro's dan bellino today now's the last
6-1 208 pounds the right-hander fires
swing and a miss
nice change-up wong chasing a pitch that
landed low and outside cardinals go with
adam wainwright he's 3-0 2.65 era
and adam will be making start number six
no score bottom of the first the cubs
scored in the first last night let's see
if they can do the same today ian happ
leads it off
he said good numbers against adam six
for eleven couple of home runs lifetime
against the cardinal right-hander yep
drives one in the air to right field and
deep if it's ferrets got a chance to
leave the yard and the cubs lead one to
nothing
off the scoreboard and straightaway
right
off the video board ian happ welcome
back to the lineup
i think that the vision is fairly clear
in that right eye of his yeah he can see
there's no doubt and he just hit one
about
400 plus feet and this is a little
cutter
ian hamp the team leader with 11 home
runs
now with 23 runs batted in
let's see if balance delay can get out
of this jam the number nine hitter
thomas hitting 0.83
here's the swing of the ground ball to
brad he's got it he'll go to third
there's the force that's the inning
and chris bryant
heaves a nice sigh of relief excellent
job by the rookie right-hander and bear
also
now there are two down and it's up to
ian happ
the bases are loaded two outs in the
second
the pitch to have a swing and a chopper
past the mound right to the shortstop to
young he steps on second retiring
hayward coming down good work adam six
unassisted down at second base we've got
paul de young coming up
base is loaded with one away here in the
third next pitch to de young is bounced
to the left side bryant to second for
one on to first and rizzo's not able to
handle it
so deyoung is safe at first and the
cardinals have tied this game the ball
just popped out of the glove of rizzo so
bases loaded for matt carpenter
at the plate
three runners aboard
and the 3-0 pitch two carpenters inside
ball four and he walked him
cardinals take a 2-1 lead in the third
inning
thank you very much we'll keep that line
moving that is 15 rbis now for matt
carpenter
it's only two to one saint lou
it's a pair of the right-hander working
on carlson the runners lead the pitch
line toward right hayward coming in he's
there he's got it
and the inning is over big out
the cardinals score twice
they leave three
let's see if baez can get a hold of one
against adam wainwright
two to one cardinals cubs batting in the
bottom of the third first of two from
wrigley field today 2-7 inning
contest next pitch of curveballs hit
hard and caught by paul deyoung a
leaping grab
deep shortstop and he showed some hops
there took a hit away from baez
and wayne oh gets through the third one
two three that sends us to the fourth
cardinals
two comes one
so the middle infielder's now at double
play depth edmund at the plate one for
two men at the corners no outs here in
the fourth for st louis
they set up inside for edmond and the
pitch is right down the middle and it's
lace to right field but it's going to
carry to hayward tagging and coming home
and
scoring is lane thomas and on the second
is colton wong
rbi sacrifice fly tommy edmond
on a strong throw from jason hayward but
the cardinals now lead three to one but
they're not done yet here in the fourth
inning paul deyoung a chance to add
on he has walked and
reached out to fielder's choice and that
produced a run the young has eight two
out rbis to lead the team nine's a
better number next pitch swing and a
line drive and it's up the middle base
hit
make it now nine
two out rbi this season for paul deyoung
to lead the cardinals he comes through
and it's a 4-1 st louis lead gadier
molina at the plate he's over one with a
walk
one and two the count
to molina to paris sets at the belt
behind leg kick and the pitch swung on
and missed
strike three side retired but not before
the cardinals
score twice on three hits so schwarber
on first base here in the bottom half of
the fourth i didn't go out wilson
contreras now at the plate he was hit by
a pitch
in the second cardinals up 4-1
and the 1-2
ground ball
goldschmidt will step on the bag nice
play on the backhand really good play
two away here in the fourth it'll bring
up the left fielder steven souza jr
bueno has allowed three hits in this
game he's walked one hit one and struck
out two curveball did he go yes he did
another strikeout for wainwright as he
gets to souza for the second time
with schwarber aboard and that brings
any in half
high fly ball well hit out into left
center it is
gone
[Music]
with another home run
his second of the game
and that makes it a four to two ball
game
happ's first home run went right down
the right field line
this one goes to left center he now has
12.
anthony rizzo represents the winning run
one and two two on
two outs
gallegos torizo
a swing and a mass for a red bird winner
rizzo strikes out leaving two on and the
cardinals and adam wainwright win game
one of the double header by a final
score of four to two